hey Geoffrey did you know the holiday
seasons are coming up oh my god really
really you know an awesome game awesome
games this is Jeff and his [ __ ]
friend Adam hey everybody this Paul talk
about this fall's like game releases
let's get started
you know as a fat overweight comic book
nerd I'm looking forward to DC Universe
Online Oh Mike you actually kind of look
for it see how it comes out I'm gonna
play as Harlequin and just keep touching
myself now he's really gonna create a
guy named sergeant man hammer and go
around showing people yeah his man
hammer that's that's my superpower the
great thing about DC Universe Online is
you don't only have to play the DC comic
book characters you can make your own
character and my character is going to
be called The Velvet serpent finally a
videogame that makes you look even more
pathetic than my comic book t-shirts and
collection of trade paperbacks thanks
Deezy you forgot the tricks t-shirt
Mahwah game i'm most excited about is
actually an expansion this fall it's
world of warcraft cataclysm I gotta say
even me a person with an active social
life when I saw the Cataclysm footage I
was like wow maybe I could just waste my
life in the basement with Jeff he's
always available when we need to get
together to film it's gonna be awesome
Morgan goblins all kinds of character
class combos new areas totally old areas
reworked check it out
you know what I'm excited for getting
laid yes but more than that the
apocalypse and that's why I can't wait
for Fallout New Vegas new Vegas not to
be confused with old Vegas better than
going to Las Vegas and killing everybody
Shenton including the slime singer I
think I think if anybody out there has
been to Las Vegas you know the only
thing that could improve it is nuclear
annihilation so go out there and get
Fallout New Vegas but make sure you get
the hookers out of there first we want
to keep
this follows the fall the motion
controllers motion [ __ ] so yeah this
fall is going to be Dance Central which
I'm really excited about on Kinect I'm
gonna get my groove on with that finally
a game where Adam and I can get our
groove on together over start every year
during this magical season I like to
pick one game that's a real turd you
know like an Iron Man 2 or an et the
video game really he just likes games
that smells like his ass I really like
shitty games and this year I think the
best crappy game is going to be our KD
of Gothic 4 not sure what it's about but
judging from the trailer it's about a
shepherd who takes up jogging but you
end up getting a sword and kill lots of
monsters that kind of look phallic so
what's the problem with that chu is so
gay my favorite game that's coming out
this fall is October 26th that's not a
game yeah I don't know if you've seen
the release lit kind of is we got rock
band 3 fable 3 Star Wars Force Unleashed
2 and WWE bravura Smackdown 2011 same
day that midnight launch is gonna be off
the shoes ooh those are gonna be the
worst most annoying lines on earth dude
I'm gonna go bankrupt that day between
the rock band expansions and all the
other games oh yeah I'm gonna go
bankrupt watching the WWE fans beat up
the rock band kids what I'm really
curious about is can a drumstick beat a
Jedi lightsaber yeah you know the
saddest things in those lines is that
the fabled fans every decision they make
while in the line affects their total
outcome so those are the video games
we're interested in but we'd love to
hear from you so please put your
comments down here and tell us what fall
video games you wanna see and also don't
forget you can always put in a video
response narcissistic loser put a great
one on for our Boba Fett vs Deadpool
video well show a little clip after the
break but we'd love to hear your video
responses as long as they're not vulgar
or self-advertising we will post them
hi my name is Dorothy is about me on
YouTube
you